[Música]
el presidente de rusia vladimir putin
agudiza la crisis al reconocer como
independientes a dos provincias
separatistas de ucrania dónetsk y vans
que además ordenó el envío de tropas a
la zona para supuestamente mantener la
paz en la región que se había
autoproclamado independiente en 2003
el consejo de seguridad de la onu se
reúne esta noche de emergencia mientras
que eeuu anunció sanciones económicas
que prohíben invertir en la región del
donbass europa también prepara medidas
tenemos reportes desde washington y
bruselas
el aborto se despenalizó en colombia con
cinco votos a favor y cuatro en contra
la corte constitucional decidió que la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo se
puede hacer en todos los casos hasta la
semana número 24 de gestación
conectaremos con bogotá
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 yo soy madre clara
calle
empezamos en rusia donde el presidente
vladimir putin agrava la crisis que vive
con occidente por el despliegue de sus
tropas en territorio ucraniano y
reconoció dos provincias separatistas de
ucrania como independientes se trata de
dones y lugansk putin ordenó el envío de
tropas a las que llama de mantenimiento
de paz para que operen en la región lo
que aumenta los temores de occidente de
que el kremlin ordene la invasión de
territorio ucraniano les contamos más en
el informe de gabriel coches y arianna
villacorta
vladimir putin firmó un decreto que
reconoce la independencia de dónetsk y
lugansk las dos regiones separatistas
del este ucraniano
consideró necesario tomar una decisión
que debería haberse tomado hace tiempo
reconocer inmediatamente la
independencia y la soberanía de la
república popular de donges y de la
república popular de lugansk tras este
reconocimiento putin anunció el envío de
fuerzas militares supuestamente para
garantizar la paz y pidió a ucrania el
fin de las operaciones militares
pedimos a los que tomaron y mantienen el
poder en quiet que pongan fin
inmediatamente a las actividades de
combate de lo contrario toda la
responsabilidad de la posible
continuación del derramamiento de sangre
recaerá enteramente en la conciencia del
régimen que gobierna el territorio de
ucrania
previamente el líder de la
autoproclamada república de lugansk
había pedido a putin que interviniera
para según él salvar miles de vidas
para evitar la muerte masiva de la
población civil de la republica de la
que 300.000 son ciudadanos de rusia le
pido que reconozca la soberanía e
independencia de la república popular de
lugansk zubiri ni kitts y nevis y más
grandes que en estas regiones prorrusas
de la cuenca del donbass muchos
habitantes ya tienen pasaportes rusos
entregados por putin en done es una
región de dos millones de habitantes
varias personas salieron a la calle para
clamar su decisión ondeando banderas
rusas
ucrania respondió solicitando una
reunión de emergencia del consejo de
seguridad de la onu este organismo se
reunirá esta misma noche luego de que
eeuu y seis países más elevarán la misma
solicitud además el mandatario ucraniano
volodymyr scheleske conversó con su
homólogo estadounidense joe biden quien
anunció dos sanciones que prohíben
inversiones en las provincias
separatistas entre otras medidas antes
desde washington nuestro corresponsal
cristóbal vázquez nos explicó de qué se
trata la orden ejecutiva anunciado por
el gobierno de bailén y a quienes
afectaría
esta orden ejecutiva afectaría a
estadounidenses que invierten que hacen
actividades comerciales y que financian
empresas o individuos en estas dos
regiones en dones y luhansk y pues
también afecta a cualquier individuo
coopere en esa región precisamente lo
que llama la atención es que la casa
blanca no ha anunciado todavía sanciones
formalmente a rusia a pesar precisamente
de que no solamente por tim haya
reconocido estas dos regiones como
independientes sino también que haya
enviado a militares para estas acciones
para este actividad de paz que él llama
en estas regiones hay que resaltar que
también el departamento de estado
concretamente el secretario de estado-
anthony blinken condenó estas acciones y
estas palabras de vladimir putin le dijo
que van completamente en contradicción a
lo que había dicho ya lo que se había
comprometido anteriormente rusia y que
además pues viola cualquier tipo de
derecho internacional y de norma
internacional por su parte de la unión
europea y el consejo europeo también
anunciaron que aplicarán sanciones
contra rusia nuestra corresponsables nos
ampliaba más temprano desde bruselas
las reacciones no se han hecho esperar
aquí en bruselas tras el reconocimiento
por parte de vladimir putin de los
territorios separatistas de donets y
lugansk en un comunicado conjunto la
presenta de la comisión europea y el
presidente del consejo europeo charles
michel así como el jefe de la diplomacia
josep borrell han recordado que este
reconocimiento de los territorios es una
violación flagrante del derecho
internacional de los acuerdos de minsk y
de la integridad territorial de ucrania
y por lo tanto la unión reaccionará con
sanciones los rumores en sucedido a lo
largo del día que ha coincidido además
con la reunión de los cancilleres
europeos aquí en bruselas en cualquier
caso el jefe de la diplomacia europea
josep borrell ha dicho que este
reconocimiento tendrá consecuencias y de
hecho pondrá sobre la mesa a los
ministros de exteriores sanciones qué
tipo de sanciones se van a poder aplicar
es algo que aún se tiene que discutir
así lo aseguran varios países europeos
porque creen que no es lo mismo un
reconocimiento que una anexión así que
falta ver qué tipo de sanción es algo
que puede ocurrir en los próximos días
así lo podremos saber en cualquier caso
la unión europea asegura que actuará con
firmeza y con unidad el primer ministro
de reino unido boris johnson relajó las
restricciones contra el hobbit 19 en
inglaterra al tiempo que la reina isabel
segunda combate esta enfermedad a partir
de este jueves quienes den positivo ya
no tendrán que aislarse en el país
además el primero afirmó que eliminará
las pruebas gratuitas desde el primero
de abril johnson levantó las
restricciones como parte del plan que
llama vivir con el kobe 19 y a pesar de
que científicos y opositores políticos
han criticado sus decisiones para
hacerle frente a la pandemia escuchemos
lo que dijo
hasta el primero de abril les seguiremos
aconsejando que se queden en casa si dan
positivo pero después de eso animaremos
a las personas con kobe y con síntomas
de kobe a que ejerzan su responsabilidad
personal sólo porque los niveles de
inmunidad son tan altos y las muertes
están ahora por debajo de lo que
normalmente se esperaría para esta época
del año que podemos levantar esta
el monte etna en la isla italiana de
sicilia volvió a entrar en erupción por
su cráter sureste y ha obligado a cerrar
el aeropuerto de la capital catania
durante este lunes se pudo apreciar una
columna de humo y cenizas de hasta 10
kilómetros de altura la erupción ha
generado asimismo dos ríos de lava que
se extienden hacia el este y el suroeste
el etna ya tuvo una erupción en este
mismo cráter el pasado 10 de febrero
en canadá el parlamento reanudó el
debate sobre la ley de emergencias que
invocó el primer ministro justin crudo
para frenar las manifestaciones de los
transportistas en contra de las medidas
por el cob y 19 los legisladores
comenzaron la discusión desde el pasado
jueves pero las protestas obligaron a
aplazar la sesión hoy trudeau defendió
la medida argumentando que las amenazas
persistentes requieren medidas que
permanezcan al menos por ahora esto fue
lo que dijo
enfoque activarle de emergencia fue
necesario
las fuerzas de seguridad y la agencia de
seguridad se apoyaron en ella para
asegurar áreas en ottawa y los pasos
fronterizos
evitó que el dinero extranjero llegara
seguir financiando los bloqueos ilegales
y asegurar que nuestras fronteras
permanecieran abiertas
argentina desplegó cerca de 160
brigadistas para luchar contra los
incendios forestales que hay en las
provincias de corrientes y de misiones
un escenario similar vive paraguay donde
las que más afectan también la
producción de soya y la calidad del aire
arianna villacorta tiene los detalles
mis seis aviones tres helicópteros
159 brigadistas y todo el personal de
apoyo convocado por el servicio
argentino de manejo del fuego logran
contener los incendios forestales que
azotan las provincias de corrientes y
misiones desde enero por lo que el
gobierno pidió ayuda a estados unidos
brasil y bolivia y corrientes llama la
atención de toda la argentina obviamente
acaba de vivir una tragedia corrientes
pero hemos puesto todas nuestras fuerzas
para ayudar porque la argentina es una
no hay una argentina de accidente en
argentina periférica no hay pueblitos y
ciudades hay argentinos que necesitan de
que la argentina te levante
más de 600 mil hectáreas ya fueron
consumidas por las llamas entre los
argentinos hay especial preocupación por
las plantaciones de yerba mate crucial
en su dieta que se encuentran en
corrientes
paraguay que limita con esa provincia
argentina también se ha visto afectada
por el fuego este país el cuarto
exportador de soja en el mundo advirtió
que la cosecha puede disminuir hasta un
60% este año eso significa
aproximadamente entre 2500 y 3000
millones de dólares menos que no van a
ingresar a nuestra economía los
productores de carne también temen que
la escasez de pastos genere cuantiosas
pérdidas entretanto las autoridades
alertaron que la calidad del aire es
crítica en asunción por lo que el
ministerio de salud recomendó permanecer
en el interior con puertas y ventanas
cerradas
ahora vamos a colombia la corte
constitucional despenalizó el aborto
durante las primeras 24 semanas de
gestación antes de esto las mujeres sólo
podían abortar en tres escenarios cuando
estuviera en riesgo la salud de la madre
cuando el feto tuviera una malformación
grave o cuando el embarazo fuera
producto de una violación nuestra
periodista marina sardiña nos ampliaba
previamente desde bogotá
en colombia se pone a la vanguardia en
materia de derechos para las mujeres
este lunes la corte constitucional
despenalizó el aborto hasta la semana 24
del embarazo recordemos que en el país
desde el año 2006 el aborto está
despenalizado pero dentro de un sistema
de tres causales de había riesgo para la
vida de la mujer en caso de violación o
malformación del feto hoy la corte
constitucional votó con cinco votos a
favor y cuatro en contra la
despenalización del aborto hasta la
semana 24 ninguna mujer podrá ser
criminalizada por este acceder a un
aborto hasta esta semana y después
imperará el sistema de causales que ya
venía esperando desde el año 2006 desde
primera hora de la mañana las
agrupaciones feministas estuvieron
presentes frente a la corte para
exigirle su aprobación también había
grupos que estaban en contra de la
despenalización del aborto pero
finalmente esto se ha convertido en una
fiesta para las mujeres colombianas que
están aquí presentes celebrando este
fallo histórico que marca un hito para y
es que colombia se convierte en uno de
los países de latinoamérica con las
leyes menos restrictivas en materia de
este derecho y que sigue la estela de
países como argentina o algunos estados
mexicanos
el poder judicial de perú inició el
juicio oral contra el ex mandatario
ollanta humala por presunto lavado de
dinero en las campañas electorales de
2006 y 2011 así se convierte en el
primer ex presidente peruano llevado a
juicio por aportes de 'break' y es que
él va acusado de supuestamente haber
recibido dinero de esa empresa brasileña
y del gobierno de venezuela para
financiar su candidatura presidencial la
fiscalía pide 20 años de prisión para el
ex mandatario y 26 para su esposa nadine
heredia mientras que pide penas menores
para otros miembros de la familia
las muertes en la ciudad brasileña de
petrópolis ascienden a 181 lo que
convierte a la catástrofe en la mayor de
la historia de la ciudad son las cifras
que dio este lunes el cuerpo de bomberos
que recuerda que aún quedan alrededor de
100 personas desaparecidas tras siete
días de búsqueda durante la mañana de
este lunes tuvieron que pararse las
labores por el intenso viento fueron
reanudadas posteriormente pero se espera
que llueva durante toda la jornada
en senegal miles de manifestantes
marcharon en contra de la homosexualidad
el código penal ya condena a las
relaciones sexuales entre personas del
mismo sexo con hasta 5 años de cárcel
pero los manifestantes quieren que la
homosexualidad sea criminalizada con
penas más severas las protestas
surgieron luego de que los legisladores
votaron en contra de una propuesta que
endurecía las sanciones más detalles en
el siguiente informe
miles de senegaleses marcharon en la
capital dakar contra la homosexualidad
después de que el parlamento rechazara
un texto que pretendía endurecer aún más
las leyes en contra de la comunidad lgtb
el mensaje está claro
pedimos que la asamblea nacional
criminalice la homosexualidad en senegal
simplemente si no lo hacen echaremos a
los diputados del poder y traeremos
otros que estén dispuestos a votar esta
ley
sin embargo el código penal ya sanciona
severamente las relaciones sexuales
entre personas del mismo sexo imponiendo
sanciones de entre 1 y 5 años de cárcel
legislación criticada por las
organizaciones de derechos humanos pero
insuficiente para los manifestantes la
llamada la movilización fue hecha por
125 asociaciones reunidas adentro de un
mismo colectivo la oposición a los
derechos del eje betis se ha convertido
en una fuerza de movilización política
de los tradicionalistas que denuncian
una influencia occidental en el país
no puedo acabar sin decir a las naciones
unidas que su agenda está condenada al
fracaso en senegal
nunca la inclusión de la comunidad lgtb
tendrá lugar en nuestro querido país de
la hospitalidad
de los 45 países de áfrica subshariana
28 tienen una legislación que reprime la
homosexualidad
así llegamos al final de nuestra emisión
informativa los invitamos a que
consulten más en nuestras redes sociales
y también que accedan a nuestra página
web france24 puntocom
nos vemos aquí para más información de
toda la actualidad internacional
[Música]